die neue spd spitze machte den eindruck
als möchte sie vor allem eins ordentlich
schulden machen und richtig viel geld
ausgeben da muss man schon fragen echt
jetzt wollte er das eigentlich ist
finanzminister scholz ja gar nicht so
wie wir ihn auf dem cover zeigen
er ist erst der typ disziplinierte
haushälter aber den kurs in der spd den
geben jetzt die neuen vorsitzenden vor
und norbert walter borjans umsatz gästen
ist die schwarze null so gar nicht
heilig bestätigt sich hier mal wieder
das alte vorurteil dass die
sozialdemokraten einfach nicht mit geld
umgehen können dass es nicht ganz so
leicht ist erklärt meyer brankovic in
unserer titelgeschichte
denn über sinn und unsinn der schwarzen
null können sich ökonom trefflich
streiten und nicht nur die ich habe ich
den artikel geschichte mal wieder an die
unruhe geben weil ich wissen wollte was
denken studenten eigentlich wird die
schwarzen und die antwort hat mich
überrascht
nicht nur haben sie alle eine starke
meinung zur deutschen haushaltspolitik
sie wollten auch alle metro hatten
fragen für die einen war die sache klar
sie wollen die klimaziele bis 2050 auf
jeden fall erreicht sehen koste es was
es wolle
ein schnelles internet hätten sie gerne
früher als das die anderen aber die
machen sich sorgen was denn das geld das
die regierung jetzt die hand wieder nur
die rente fließen sie auf den
finanziellen eskapaden ihrer eltern
sitzen bleiben nur wer hat jetzt recht
wurde ist das so gleich gar nicht zu
sagen
nehmen sie sich kurz zeit und ließen sie
die woche